Eric is in Lexington Kentucky hi Eric
how are you I'm better not deserved a
bank cool how can I help I got a
question about insurance I've been
working for the past couple years as a
temporary at a factory but I just
received word that in about a month I
will be hired on full-time good and so
with that comes new insurance mm-hmm and
this is the first time in the good
number of years that I've I will be
offered HSA mm-hmm and I recall you
mentioning that thank you says you have
one yes I wonder the the advantages of
it what kind of questions I should ask
make sure it's it's the good one for
myself in my family all right
97% of the people and other team members
and Ramsey solutions using HSA we offer
a PPO but we don't recommend it and I
personally use an HSA the what the HSA
is is a large a high deductible lower
premium because it's a high deductible
health insurance plan and most of them
have a hundred percent coverage once you
meet the deductible but the deductible
is high
it'll be like five thousand bucks or
seven thousand bucks or something like
that
but once you meet it it's a hundred
percent coverage after that for most of
them check yours and see some of them
have a copay but most of our hundred
percent after that does the second thing
then is is that you're allowed to invest
money into a savings account pre-tax
meaning you don't get taxed on the money
in order to pay out-of-pocket medical
bills like covering that ductile as an
example and so if you had a thousand
dollar medical bill and you just paid
for it with after-tax dollars versus
pre-tax dollars if you pay for with
pre-tax dollars it's kind of like using
seven hundred fifty or six hundred and
fifty dollars to pay for it a thousand
dollar bill because you didn't get you
get the tax break on the money going
through it's tax-free money to pay your
medical bills with running through that
HSA and so through the savings account
itself so if you can fund that
even if you don't fund that the plan is
just cheaper premiums is what it amounts
to
and but here's what it works best for it
that that high deductible and covers a
hundred percent after that plan if again
not all of them are that way but most of
them are it works really good if you're
very very sick or someone has chronic
illness all the time so you're always
blowing through the deductible you come
out cheaper with this because it picks
up a bunch of it at it keep picks up
hundred percent after that the other
time it works out great is if you're
really healthy like the Ramseys we don't
use insurance hardly at all I haven't
ever in my life knock on wood but I mean
very very few health claims on me and
Sharron and even when our kids would
home with the kids so we very seldom use
the health use the went through the
deductible and what that means is we
just ended up with cheaper premiums okay
so that's how it works and that's what
the advantages are your self insuring
I'm sorry the investing part is that
that's an addition to the premium you
know yes yes the premiums are cheaper on
the insurance portion but then you can
choose if you want to to put money into
the HSA now I would not put money in
there until you've gotten through baby
step three
unless you have a known medical event
coming up and you want to put enough
money in there to cover that event in a
given year yeah I already there
working on and off the mortgage okay
cool then you might want to use it as a
methodology for saving that's what I've
been doing but again I haven't used it
I've got almost 150,000 bucks in the
stupid thing because I've never used it
I just keep throwing the money in there
and it's actually become another become
one of the few tax-free things I can
still do because of my income being high
okay so it's it's a cool I'm a big fan
of the HSA I think it would have solved
a lot of things had we leaned on that
instead of some of the stupid Obamacare
stuff we did but I think it was the way
to go and I we maybe we'll go back there
when before the nation goes broke trying
to fund this other crap but um it's a
mess alright that's the deal man
Thanks hey guys Rachael Cruz here hope
you enjoyed that video from the Dave
Ramsey show if you want to watch another
great video check out my video three
things you should consider renting right
over here or click the link in the
description below